we begin in hong kong where a court has
convicted a prominent lawyer and human
rights activist of inciting an
unauthorized assembly
chauhan tong was sentenced to 15 months
in prison for organizing a vigil for the
victims of china's bloody crackdown on
protesters in tiananmen square in 1989.
she was arrested a day before the
anniversary of the killings last june
hong kong media attack who jimmy lai has
already been jailed for 13 months for
joining that vigil
from on that verdict let's cross over to
hong kong where our correspondent
phoebe kong is standing by phoebe what's
the significance of this verdict
well the uh the charges uh relating to
this sentence was basically about the um
the articles and the speech of childs
that have that she has released ahead of
june 4th 2021 that charges were related
to
facebook and twitter posts are titled
lighting a candle is not a crime stand
one's ground where chao hong tong posted
on her social media accounts and also an
other article published on the new local
newspaper named candlelight carries the
weights of conscience and hong kong
people persevere in telling the truth so
um these kind of speeches and opinions
expressed by chao was become become
evidence of her conviction um that
during the ruling the magistrates
amy chant told
the public and also um defendant that
she believed that these kind of posts
and articles are meant to encourage and
persuade the members of public to attend
the banned vigil and that's why they
amounted to incitement to the
unauthorized
assembly
but
we have observed the chao hong tong told
of the court after the verdict in tears
that uh she read out testimonies of the
family some of the victims of the 1989
crackdown in beijing and
she thought that the courts should
consider and heard the voice of those
victims that this kind of voice were
that the authorities trying to buried
and silence in this case and it said
that it can be forcing that public space
to this question for
commemoration and massacre
would be further
silenced
tell us more about xiaohang tong hushi
is a 36 year old barrister and also the
vice chairman of the now defunct hong
kong alliance which is um the uh the
visual organizing group um of the very
iconic uh commemoration in hong kong the
past three decades over three decades
actually
but the alliance was
forced to dissolve uh in 2021 after
police investigation
under the national security law and also
a series of
arrests on his core members including
chao hong tong and chairman lee checking
a very prominent pro-democracy vectors
in hong kong um that ciao hong tong is
one of the key factors
in the commemoration campaign in hong
kong which was very iconic because
this campaign has
basically distinguished hong kong from
the rest of china that hong kong
used to be one of the remaining places
on chinese soil to legally commemorate
the [ __ ]
crackdown which was still remain as a
political taboo in china but now
it seems that this all
has gone
phobicon reporting from hong kong there
thank you phoebe
bronson chan is chairman of the hong
kong journalists association
can you explain the significance of chao
hong kong's verdict to to our viewers
around the world
oh it means
birthday
well um i i think
this is the first person that
have been prosecuted by the um
on the june 4th incident
assembly
after the diagonalizer and this was
quite sad
for for the imprisonment
we've also been following the closure of
independent media outlets in hong kong
over the past couple days how have you
been personally affected because you
worked at the stant news which closed
last week after a big raid and rests
yes i worked in standards before and
it suddenly shut down in
last week after
several management members have been
arrested
and i have been searched by police my
house search by police
for me it is a very sad day a very sad
moment now i lost
my job i lost my colleagues i lost my
identity of being a journalist
i'm still trying to to um um
have a velvet on it but i i'm still
trying to um
get get get well off of my situation and
what would you say hong kong has lost
here
um
i'm afraid that the
loss of such these two media
organizations the daniel and the news
made um showed a signal to us that
the independent media
cannot be existed in hong kong anymore
i'm afraid this
and and furthermore that
and
we cannot find any
very um organized media organization
which has a
more independent uh stance
in hong kong
can i ask you another question hong
kong's leader carrie lam says these
recent closures do not indicate a
decline in press freedom as the
decisions were made by the outlets
themselves what do you say to that
what i would like to say is
everyone in hong kong and around the
world understood what happened
if they have not
getting any regrets of their staff
safety
i
i would commend it's a scary thing i'm
saying but i'm just
i think that everyone
tough times for you as well personally
uh good luck in in in finding a new job
but thank you very much for uh
explaining the situation for us here on
dw
bye bye